chacun christophe hondelatte
elle saute sur tout ce qui bouge louis
va se retourner dans sa tombe là
franchement je le deviens un peu fier de
moi
alors christophe bonsoir le 28 janvier
dernier vous quittiez votre poste de
présentateur du journal de 13 heures sur
france 2 mais vous avez continué à
présenter sur cette même chaîne une
émission intitulée faites entrer
l'accusé consacré aux grandes affaires
criminelles les sujets les plus chauds
sont déclinés en livre après la josacine
et avant simone weber vous publié chez
michel lafon l'assassinât du petit
grégory la sphère rigoriste ça commence
le 16 octobre 1984
l'enfant à 4 ans est le fils unique de
christine et jean marie villemin
il disparaît il est introuvable jusqu'à
ce que son oncle reçoit un coup de fil
un coup de téléphone
je me suis vengé j'ai pris le fils du
chef
je les ai mis dans la vologne et on
retrouve le corps de grégory et va se
passer un petit événement c'est que
probablement pour pour la première fois
et je me demande même si ça a été refait
depuis on va diffuser dans la presse des
photos du corps de grégory avec avec les
pieds et les mains liées sortant de la
vologne
c'est un journaliste qui fait ce ce
scoop probablement qu on s'interrogerait
beaucoup aujourd'hui sur le relève la
nécessité de publier cette photo
n'empêche qu'elle est sorti partout et
est que l a marqué le début de cette
affaire
sans doute at-elle une responsabilité
ensuite dans la médiatisation les gens
ont tout de suite vu la victime est
évidemment elles ont été touchées par ce
petit corps sortant de l'eau glacée de
la vologne
alors le lendemain il ya une lettre du
corbeau qui se termine par voilà ma
vengeance pauvre con et donc on cherche
tout de suite non l'encouragent et d'une
certaine manière comme comment dire les
planques est à la certitude qu'on va y
arriver très vite
voilà donc un type qui menace qui dit
qui dit j'ai voulu me venger du chef ça
désigne l'entourage donc on se dit on va
faire les oncles et tantes les
beaux-frères et belles-soeurs une fois
qu'on est arrivé au bout du tour on aura
trouvé le coupable et on croit et tout
le monde a la certitude à ce moment là
que c'est affaire de jours quadeurs et
ça va durer des années
on accuse le cousin de villemain dénommé
bernard laroche qui est inculpé
d'assassinât qui est libéré d'ailleurs
trois mois après et qui est abattu d'une
balle en pleine poitrine par jean marie
villemin
mais c'est l'assassinât de la roche par
villemin des journalistes n'y sont pas
étrangers il ya eu une part d'excitation
les journalistes sont excités villemin
contre la roche
je désignerai personne parce que c'était
une atmosphère générale de de rivalités
de course au scoop de volée de photo de
ses seins on a notre profession a
pataugé dans des mises en scène de
photos aussi dans la mer de l'est que
les peluches sur le temps avec les
peluches avec c'était une époque où bon
tout ça existe peut-être encore je doute
que ça existe toujours mais c'est une
époque où les journalistes allez voir
les victimes et leur disait on peut vous
trouver un bon avocat
ouais ensuite il allait chercher un
avocat s'est passé dans l'affairé
grégory
il allait chercher l'avocat il lui
disait j'ai trouvé un bon client tu vas
te faire mousser avec sa terrible devant
les caméras mais en revanche tout de
suite
donne-moi de l'info donne moi des photos
et c'est ce qui se passe dans la sphère
grégory le jour là ils se trouvent
l'avocat pour la famille villemin il
accompagne l'avocat chez les villemin et
rentre dans la chambre de grégory et
clac clac clac clac clac clac clac qui
prend bientôt de la chambre de grégory
ses peluches etc
voilà c'est une époque où c'était
l'époque où le journal france soir qui à
l'époque était donné une immense journal
depuis divers envoyé 10 15 journalistes
sur place en même temps ça ça n'existe
que nous l'aurons bernard laroche était
assassiné d'une balle en pleine poitrine
par jean marie villemin
mais on accuse aussi christine villemin
ceux qu'on accuse la mère de la petite
victime qui est mise en examen qui est
enfoncée par un texte de marguerite
duras sublime forcément sublime et
remise elle aussi en liberté après une
grève de la faim
on envoie marguerite duras là-bas pour
écrire un article et donc elle va là bas
grade bon là
la maison devil may et elle a une sorte
d'intuition que le crime a eu lieu là et
donc si le crime a eu lieu là c'est donc
c'est la mère qui l'a tué
et elle est émerveillée par cette espèce
de révélations calendale maison elle en
fait un article
bon c'est juste du délire c'est ça ne
relève en rien et du vent les venues de
la littérature c'est n'importe quoi
mais il ya une morale à tout à attirer
de ça parce qu'aujourd'hui encore il y à
des écrivains que je ne citerai pas qui
face à des faits divers ou des
intuitions voilà ils ont des intuitions
ils n'ont pas enquêté connaissent pas le
dossier ils sont pas plonger la
procédure la réalité des faits les
intéresse pas mais ils ont des
intuitions en fait il ya un vieux
complexe c'est celui d'être de nouveau
là
finalement donc après une tentative de
suicide chez sylvie demain bénéficiera
d'un non lieu dans le procès de jean
marie villemin donc est ce que c'est un
justicier dans le cas où la roche serait
la ccin ou est-ce que c'est simplement
un assassin évidemment des circonstances
atténuantes ce type n'était dans une
pression médiatique total il était
remonté un peu comment on veut y
montrent une pendule on l'avait remonter
dans la haine contre la roche
et puis au moment où il le tue il pense
sincèrement que bernard laroche a tué
grégory donc voilà je sais pas comment
le père que nous sommes réagirions
s'humaniser ce type qui hélas a tu aimes
ou tu veux pas qu'on ait finalement ils
bénéficieront d'un verdict d'apaisement
et pourront recommencer une nouvelle vie
ouais dans la région parisienne voilà
ils vivent aujourd'hui dans la région
parisienne quand on avait fait une film
faites entrer l'accusé quand on a fait
ce livre on les a rencontrés avant ils
n'ont pas voulu participer ils ont
hésité longtemps hésité parce qu'ils ont
toujours peur que ça recommence
que chacun se refasse une opinion et bon
voilà on les a rassurés ils ne nous ont
pas mis de bâtons dans les roues mais
ils n'ont pas participé et enfin il pas
de regret là-dessus genre deux en forme
hathaway et sur comment bien en amoureux
oui et puis se sont jamais quittés quoi
ils s'aiment toujours
et dieu sait si des gens ont dû
s'interposer entre eux pour essayer de
semer la haine entre terrifiant et c'est
là où on voit quand même qu'aux
résidences à peine de mort est abolie
parce que quand on voit qu'en gros on
accuse les gens qu'on est victime comme
ça du cliché de de la presse qui veut du
sensationnel le poids des mots le choc
des photos
c'est pas faux la sogc est adaptée à la
situation
alors ça va ça c'est une belle
championne belge championne
alors aujourd'hui le mystère reste
entier non ah ben oui on il ya eu un
petit espoir puisque la génétique est
arrivé est alors bon il ya beaucoup
d'affaires ou la génétique que pour être
aujourd'hui résoudre des problèmes qui
n'ont pas résolu
autrefois mais les pièces auxquelles les
pièces ont été détruits or dans la
sphère grégory il avait encore un timbre
poste
enfin morceaux de timbres-poste et on
s'est dit qu'en des collants ce
timbre-poste probablement que le corbeau
envoyée à la lettre avait eu mec telle
table c'était l'époque où les mecs terry
table et donc laisser un peu la dn
dessous donc on s'est dit ça va être
formidable on va enfin résoudre le
problème malheureusement il n'y a pas de
traces adn exploitables insoutenable
voilà donc il y a quelqu'un qui sait
muriel bolle
à raconter deux choses dans un premier
temps c'est elle qui a accusé bernard
laroche a quitté ensuite elle s'est
rétractée donc mme muriel bol c'est en
tout cas si bernard laroche la fée ou
l'a pas fait voilà et ça ll c'est
aujourd'hui une dame qui a un secret et
on s'éclate
quelquefois on va arriver un moment où
tout ça n'aura plus d'importance sur le
plan judiciaire peut-être qu'elle aura
envie de soulager sa conscience qu'elle
sait quelque chose
en même temps si elle a menti la
première fois et un qu'elle n'a pas vu
bernard laroche emmené grégory elle ne
sait pas mais bon il ya des gens qui
savent c'est évident quelqu'un c'est
dense dans cette région ça sortira
peut-être l affaire 2 min sik est une
des grandes affaires un peu comparable
d'ailleurs ça s'est su bien diane après
quoi elles font le vieux avec moi moi
moi je me méfie toujours de ces
histoires on sait très très longtemps
après on a plus moyen vraiment vérifier
l'horaire à c'était vrai je pense avoir
trouvé donc laissons cette affaire en
paix voilà alors christophe hondelatte
ya une autre affaire qui n'a pas été
élucidée non plus c'est votre départ de
france 2 je me demandais si vous avions
parlé au début de l'émission je me suis
dit tiens il va pas parler j'étais
inquiet il peut parler d'autre chose qui
a pris un quartier dans libération qui
n'était pas de marguerite duras et le 28
janvier vous découvrez un article où
sont mentionnés des choses qui ont trait
à votre votre vie privée je dirais et là
vous annoncez brutalement que vous
arrêtez la présentation du journal de 13
heures pour des raisons personnelles
alors benoît duquesne vous remplace au
pied levé
j'étais dans un état d'esprit j'étais un
peu fatigué à ce moment là j'ai été
victime de la trahison d'une journaliste
qui va se régler devant les tribunaux
parce que je lui en veux énormément et
j'ai estimé à ce moment là que
métier et le métier que je faisais et
espèce de petite gloire que j'avais
comme présentateur de journal télévisé
ne méritait pas cette souffrance-là et
j'ai dit basta au revoir
voilà c'est tout et ça mérite pas plus
d'explications est ce qu'on peut
vous êtes
non y'a quand même des choses qui sont
sortis dans la presse dont on peut vous
demander à partir du moment où ouais
c'est christophe quand vous dites garder
la pêche
ouais bon au départ on dit il a trouvé
un geek comme ami de l'homme en noir
bonsoir ou salut bande de nazes
métallurgie la trouve un guide bon et
puis on s'aperçoit qu'en fait se garder
la pêche est destiné à quelqu'un qui
n'ont forcé de signer à quelqu'un le
premier jour mais ensuite c'est destiné
à tout le monde c'est destiné à tous les
gens qui sont là et dans les centaines
de lettres que j'ai reçus depuis les
gens l'ont pris pour c'est important
c'est pourquoi les gens le prenaient à
presque moi j'avais dans ma tête le
premier jour le 6 septembre à 13h45
quand j'ai dit garder la pêche il y
avait effectivement un petit gymnich
adressé on peut pas le dire mais nos
répétitions et de dire si vous voulez ça
a déjà été dit mais moi je maintiens que
c'était privé je veux dire je vois là il
ya eu des délires autour de ça mais je
disais garder la pêche
le premier jour une expression qui me
plaisait bien je savais que j'avais que
je connaissais quelqu'un qui
identifierait ça comme un clin d'oeil et
de là où une épée puisqu'il était en
prison ça c'est notoriété maintenant
public pas de mon fait mais ça a été
révélé de ci de là mais qu'est ce qui a
fait flamber ce temps là j'espère que
non qu'est ce qu'il ya d'extraordinaire
franchement oui vous vous allez voir des
gens dans les prisons ce qui déjà vous
honore deuxièmement vous devenez ami
avec un prisonnier
ce prisonnier est tout seul dans sa
prison à la fin du journal de 13 heures
rue dit garder la pêche
qu'est-ce que saad ben voilà donc je
vois des prisonniers j'ai dit garder la
pêche à un prisonnier voilà lieu le
problème c'est que il ya quelqu'un la
rédaction de france 2 qui avait été
victime rentrait dans six mois mais
c'est la vérité
ouais mais je veux pas entrer dans cette
ville je voulais pas rentrer et sa
rentrée dans l'histoire je comprends
mais c'est vrai que c'est un hasard
absolument extraordinaire c'est à dire
que à la rédaction de france 2 il ya
quelqu'un dont la famille a été victime
du garçon à quibou dit de garder la
pêche
et c'est ça qui a cac qui a fait que
vous avez dit garder la banane
d'ailleurs après moi c'est ce qui fait
qu'au bout d'un moment je me suis dit
que j'allais pas monté avec ça mais si
l'histoire sur lequel je veux pas
revenir pouvez pas vous imaginer
bon c'est peut-être un
un trait de notre métier est un sale
traits de notre métier mais ça me paraît
très très loin tout ça et de tout ça
j'ai plus est ce que vous regrettez ce
coup de chaud cette espèce de m mais non
je suis désolé je suis désolé de le dire
d'abord je peux juste pas un caractère à
regretter et je ne regrette pas d'avoir
été fidèle à mes convictions et
finalement blessé par une trahison voilà
et quand un type est peintre et puis qui
peint sur son échelle et qui dit y font
chier il descendre l'échelle hissbach
alors ça se voit moins
c'est moins publics bons vacances et un
présentateur de journaux ça un peu plus
de visibilité mais au fond ça n'est
jamais qu'une toile air ordinaire c'est
plein de français m'ont dit qu'ils se
reconnaissaient parce que c'est un vieux
fantasme de coups de craquer l'apport
voilà je me tiens je me tire voilà je me
tire et alors les gens évidemment ce
qu'ils comprennent - c'est que la place
est enviable et enviée oui voilà les
gens à l'école et la banque et il a dû
passer une vie avoue âge à chercher
cette place là et alors ils tirent pas
clair et en fait je suis resté jusqu'à
la fin de la saison quand même oui oui
je pensais rester jusqu'à la fin de
saison très honnêtement oui même si à
plusieurs reprises j'avais proposé de
partir parce que c'est difficile parce
que c'était difficile que les audiences
ne rigolez pas etc
je peux en vivre tellement de m'attarder
là dessus mais mais bon voilà c'est un
coup de tête mais moi j'ai pas caractère
a regretté les coups de tête
en plus on peut pas faire marche arrière
1 on peut parvenir
donc c'est fait c'est fait et je vis
très bien avec et je regrette simplement
d'avoir probablement au fait de la peine
à des gens qui m'avaient fait confiance
par exemple je regrette beaucoup d'avoir
fait de la peine à arlette chabot je
pense qu'arlette m'avez fait confiance
vous avez déclaré récemment je ne peux
pas regarder le 13 heures de france 2
j'ai l'impression que benoît duquesne
d'or dans mon lit et couche avec ma
femme je vais regretter un peu ça je
regrette mes regrets ça brasse parce que
c'est une vraie famille regrette surtout
c'est une formule
rigolote mais je la regrette parce qu'au
fond elle traduit quelque chose qui
n'est pas vrai c'est que c'est un peu
comme si j'avais conservé que ce journal
était le mien un jour là qui est
fabriqué par 400 journalistes à france 2
donc non il fait là je sais que des gens
en ont pris ombrage présenterait un qui
prend ombrage de beaucoup de choses donc
là il a eu raison de prendre ombrage de
sovo ce que je voyais je veux bien
reconnaître que une plongée d'une icône
il atteint voilà vous regardez jean
pierre pernaut maintenant comme tout le
monde j'ai malheureusement j'appartiens
à cette catégorie trop nombreuses gens
qui regardent pas le journal à 13 heures
parce qu'ils font autre chose et c'est
bien le problème du journal de 13 heures
c'est à dire que les gens actifs le
regard peu et donc c'est difficile de et
les gens âgés ont la télécommande bloqué
sur l'oeil
christophe hondelatte j'ai publié chez
michel lafon